Germany remains in shock following the
death of an 8 year old boy after he was
pushed onto tracks at Frankfurt Central
Station he and his mother were shoved in
front of a high-speed train on Monday
somehow she was able to roll out of the
way the boy was killed instantly
an arrest was made and investigators
have revealed more information about the
man in custody
he's a 40-year old married father of
three originally from Eritrea who's held
asylum status in Switzerland since 2008
the suspect had been considered
well-integrated by swiss authorities but
in last Thursday a warrant for his
arrest was issued after he was accused
of threatening a neighbor the suspects
now charged with murder and attempted
murder but police still have no motive
in an effort to head off a racial
backlash the German interior minister
said people should not focus on the
suspects ethnicity
this horrible act in Frankfort should
not be used in order to put blame on old
migrants and to put them all under a
general suspicion sat alongside the
interior minister senior police
officials acknowledged a number of
recent violent incidents in the country
and the need to reassure the public over
their safety despite the fact that fewer
crimes are being committed in general we
see public confidence and decline and we
see more and more polarized crimes on
different sides of the political
spectrum one of the leaders of the
anti-immigration alternative for Germany
party has courted controversy with a
series of tweets about the murder and
the suspect and political rivals were
quick to fire back protect the citizens
of our country finally instead of having
this limitless welcomed culture the
mergers eritrean didn't come to Germany
in 2015 but arrived in Switzerland in
2006 so can we just go to the point no
the limitless welcoming culture leads to
an even more threatening security
situation throughout Europe
an eight-year-old child dies as a result
of a terrible act in Frankfurt and what
does the AFD do they spread their
disgusting and racist baiting on Twitter
it is spreading hate and stirring up
people against each other
a week ago another Eritrean man was the
victim of a drive-by shooting which
police suspect was motivated by
xenophobia police though have ruled out
any connection with the Frankfurt
railway station incident the public's
confidence in the state's ability to
keep them safe has been shaken with
Islamic leaders saying they feel at risk
after a series of bomb threats against
mosques Muslims are deeply insecure and
the state has a duty to take
confidence-building measures the Federal
Republic has the responsibility to let
all people exercise their religion free
of fear and violence our coexistence is
at risk
so our democracy that is unacceptable
they Hoffa and other senior figures in
politics and security are promising
extra measures beefed up CCTV and the
likes but they have a bigger battle on
their hands as they have to convince
people that the powers that be are
capable of looking out for their safety
Peter Oliver RT Berlin
you